[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome to this
episode of "Click to Deploy,"
the series where we
show you how easy it
is to deploy solutions from
the Google Cloud Marketplace.
In this episode,
we'll be reviewing
how to set up a LAMP stack
through the marketplace.
LAMP stands for Linux operating
system, Apache HTTP server,
MySQL database management
system, and PHP programming
language.
It's a set of
open-source software
used to build web applications.
We'll start by searching
for "LAMP stack" in the GCP
Marketplace.
There are a few options
from different vendors,
each with their own version
of Linux, differing security
models, as well
as support models.
For this demo, we'll choose the
Google Click to Deploy option.
Let's do a quick run-through of
the summary of the deployment.
This specific deployment will
be launched on a single VM
of my size choosing.
As always, the
pricing information
displays a high-level
estimate of charges.
Once we customize
our deployment,
we'll receive a more
detailed breakdown.
Let's start the launch.
Similar to many marketplace
deployment options,
we'll pick a name and the
zone in which we'll deploy.
I'll stick with the default
name and zone, US West 2B.
We can also continue
with the default machine
type, which is an
E2 small, having
two VCPUs and 2 gigs of memory.
Let's keep the default for boot
disk and networking options.
We'll end with making sure our
VM can accept HTTP and HTTPS
traffic from the internet.
Before you deploy, you can
see a final estimate of costs
with the custom options you
configured for deployment.
By clicking Details, you can
expand for an itemized cost
breakdown.
Keep in mind,
these costs may not
include charges for
networking and monitoring.
We'll launch and give
it a minute to spin up.
Let's take a look at our
deployment information.
Clicking the site address will
display our default LAMP web
application.
This is just the
landing page for Apache.
One of the first
suggested next steps
is to change the MySQL
temporary password.
So we can do that by using
the PHP My Admin web interface
that's provided to us.
Now that we're more
secure, let's go back
and change our landing
page to something custom.
We can SSH into the VM
and act as the root user
to customize the
index.html page.
We can refresh our
IP URL, and now we
have our very simple,
yet customized, LAMP
stack deployed at the click of
a button using the Google Cloud
Marketplace.
If you enjoyed this video,
please subscribe and hit
the Like button below.
We encourage you to check
out the GCP Marketplace
and deploy this
solution on your own.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]